nos dicen mueve el punto anaranjado a 3
enteros 39 centésimas en la recta
numérica aquí comienzo con tres enteros
dos décimas y aquí en este otro extremo
tengo tres enteros cinco décimas quiere
decir que de aquí acá hay tres décimas y
vemos que de aquí acá está dividido en 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 17
18 19 20 21 22 23 24 25 26 27 28 29 30
en 30 partes iguales entonces son tres
décimas divididas en 30 partes iguales
quiere decir que en estas marcas en
estas rayitas más grandes es donde van a
estar mis otras décimas si aquí tengo
tres enteros dos décimas aquí van a
estar tres enteros tres décimas
aquí tres enteros cuatro décimas y bueno
aquí tres enteros cinco décimas cada
décima está dividida en diez partes
iguales de aquí acá tengo diez rayitas
quiere decir que esta décima está
dividido en diez y cada rayita es una
décima de una décima o lo que es lo
mismo una centésima entonces nos piden
tres enteros treinta y nueve centésimas
aquí queremos que comenzamos con dos
décimas que es lo mismo que veinte
centésimas
aquí hay treinta centésimas o tres
décimas y de estas treinta centésimas
comenzamos a contar 31 centésimas 32
centésimas 33 34 35 36 37 38 39
centésimas
es la marca que nos están pidiendo aquí
debemos colocar nuestro puntito naranja
vamos a comprobar la respuesta
es correcta vamos a hacer otra pregunta
mueve el punto anaranjado a nueve
enteros cuatro centésimas en la recta
numérica es esta interesante vemos que
comenzamos con ocho enteros nueve
décimas y terminamos con nueve enteros
una décima de estas nueve décimas aquí
vamos a tener diez décimas y aquí 11
décimas por eso es que también pasamos
de este 88 enteros a nueve enteros
porque aquí tenemos dos décimas esta
marca de aquí va a ser la de nueve
enteros 0 décimas y nos están
preguntando 9 enteros 4 centésimas
vemos que cada décima esta es una décima
y esta es otra están divididos en uno
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
nueve diez lo mismo acá cada una está
dividida en diez partes iguales o lo que
es lo mismo cada décima está dividido en
diez cada rayita es una décima de una
décima o una centésima sí aquí tenemos
nuestros nueve enteros cero décimas y
cero centésimas pues vamos a contar las
centésimas aquí son cero una centésima
dos centésimas tres centésimas cuatro
centésimas nueve enteros cuatro
centésimas movemos nuestro puntito acá
comprobamos nuestra respuesta es
correcta y una vez que tenemos la
respuesta correcta no nos hace ningún
daño ver las pistas que tienen aquí por
ejemplo
arriba hemos trazado la recta numérica
desde ocho enteros nueve décimas hasta
nueve enteros una décima
dividida en veinte partes iguales aquí
hay diez partes de división y aquí hay
otras diez partes de división veinte
partes iguales vemos la siguiente pista
la recta está dividida en 20 partes lo
que significa que si yo tomo esta
cantidad 9 enteros una décima y la resto
a la de aquí ocho enteros nueve décimas
y esto lo divido entre 20 me van a dar
que cada división es igual a una
centésima muy bien aquí está la marca de
nueve enteros cero décimas y cero
centésimas es lo que hicimos para
encontrar el resultado veamos la
siguiente pista si partimos de lo que
queremos encontrar nueve enteros cuatro
centésimas es igual a ocho enteros 9
décimas esta cantidad con la que
iniciamos más nuestros incrementos de
una centésima multiplicados por 14
quiere decir que tuvimos que movernos 14
lugares para posicionar este puntito por
lo tanto mover el punto anaranjado 14
lugares te pondré en la posición 9
enteros 4 centésimas
vamos a hacer otro problema mueve el
punto anaranjado a 5 enteros 93
centésimas en la recta numérica vemos
que iniciamos en 52 7 décimas
tenemos aquí estas marcas y llegamos a
seis enteros cero décimas quiere decir
que aquí hay de 5.7 5.8 5.96 tenemos
tres décimas aquí aquí hay una décima y
aquí hay otra cada una de ellas está
dividida en diez partes iguales o lo que
es lo mismo centésimas
aquí nos piden poner el punto anaranjado
entonces en cinco enteros 93 centésimas
quedamos que estas siete décimas o
setenta centésimas están aquí en esta
marca tenemos ocho décimas y 80
centésimas y aquí tenemos nueve décimas
o 90 centésimas a partir de aquí de las
90 centésimas vamos a contar hasta
llegar al 93 centésimas
90 91 92 y 93 aquí es donde va a estar
este punto naranja vamos a comprobar la
respuesta es correcta y vamos a ver de
nuevo las pistas que nos dan aquí la
primera pista es arriba hemos trazado
una recta numérica de cinco enteros
siete décimas hasta seis enteros cero
décimas dividida en treinta partes
iguales siguiente pista la recta está
dividida en treinta partes lo que
significa que esta cantidad menos esta
otra dividido en treinta en estos
treinta pedazos es igual a punto 01 o lo
que es lo mismo una centésima y vamos
viendo las siguientes pistas y aquí
incluso nos están marcando el valor en
donde se encuentran las décimas y aquí
nos indican en donde debemos colocar
este punto yo espero que esto haya sido
útil y los invito a que vayan a la
plataforma y realicen estos ejercicios